LAWYERS --
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER
WELCOME TO "UCKER
WELCOME TO "TUKER
WELCOME TO "TUCKR
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HERE'S WHERE WE ARE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS CONTINUE TO DIE IN
THEIR PRIME FROM DRUG ODs.
THE MIDDLE CLASS IS STILL
SHRINKING, HOUSING CRISIS IN
OUR CITIES CRUSHING
GENERATION OF AMBITIOUS
YOUNG PEOPLE.
CHINA'S ECONOMY IS ABOUT TO
OVERTAKE OURS.
THAT'S ALL THE BAD NEWS
RIGHT THERE.
HAVE NO FEAR.
HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS.
WASHINGTON IS ON IT.
YOUR REPRESENTATIVES IN THE
CAPITAL CITY, THIS CITY,
JUST SPENT THEIR THIRD DAY
IN A ROW YELLING AT EACH
OTHER ABOUT A PHONE CALL
DONALD TRUMP ONCE MADE TO
SOME GUY IN UKRAINE.
IN OTHER WORDS THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL OF THE
PRESIDENT ROLLS ON TONIGHT.
IF NOTHING ELSE, THAT MEANS
THAT AMATEUR THESE MEAN AND
FULL TIME CONGRESSMAN ADAM
SCHIFF GETS TO TRY OUT NEW
PARTS FOR THE CAMERA.
YESTERDAY YOU WILL REMEMBER
SCHIFF PLAYED THE WAR TIME
GENERAL IMMINENT MILITARY
INVASION.
THE RUSSIANS ARE COMING, HE
SQUEAKED.
THE RUSSIANS ARE COMING.
WATCH.
>> AS ONE WITNESS PUT IT
DURING OUR IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY, THE UNITED STATES
AIDES UKRAINE AND HER PEOPLE
SO THAT WE CAN FIGHT RUSSIA
OVER THERE AND WE DON'T HAVE
TO FIGHT RUSSIA HERE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
WE COULD SOON FIGHT THE
RUSSIANS HERE, INST. JOHN'S
BERRY, NOT ST. PETERSBURG
STOCK UP ON MILK.
TODAY SCHIFF REVIVED THE
CHARACTER YOU SAW
THEOLOGICAL DIMENSION WAR
TIME GENERAL PLUS OLD
TESTAMENT PROPHET GEORGE
PATENT MEETS JEREMIAH
SUDDENLY DROPPING REFERENCES
TO GOD LIKE THE TWO WERE OLD
FRIENDS.
>> THANK GOD PUTIN SAID
PUTIN SAID THANK GOD NOBODY
IS ACCUSING US ANY MORE OF
INTERFERING IN U.S.
ELECTIONS NOW THEY ARE
UKRAINE.
THANK GOD PUTIN SAYS.
I DON'T THINK WE REALLY WANT
VLADIMIR PUTIN, OUR
ADVERSARY TO BE THANKING GOD
FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WISH US WELL.
WE DO NOT WANT THEM THANKING
GOD FOR OUR PRESIDENT AND
WHAT HE IS PUSHING OUT.
WE DON'T WANT THEM THANKING
GOD FOR WITHHOLDING MONEY
FROM OUR ALLIES.
>> Tucker: SAY WHAT YOU
WILL, BUT AS A PIECE IN
THEATER IT HAD LITERALLY
EVERYTHING, DASTARDLY OLD
VLADIMIR PUTIN RUBBING HIS
HANDS TOGETHER IN DIABOLICAL
GLEE.
FOOLISH AMERICANS LITTLE DO
THEY KNOW MY TROOPS WILL BE
IN PHOENIX BY NIGHT FALL.
ON OTHER SIDE GOD HIMSELF IN
HEAVEN LOOKING DOWN IN
SADNESS HOPING THIS LOST
NATION WILL FINALLY HEED
SAINT ADAM'S PROPHETIC
WARNINGS AND OBEY.
IT WAS THE AGE OLD BATTLE
GOOD VS. EVIL PLAYING OUT
RIGHT THERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR.
SENATOR JIM RICH OF IDAHO
WAS NOT IMPRESSED FELL DEAD
ASLEEP THE OTHER DAY
PROBABLY WASN'T THE ONLY ONE
TO DO IT.
IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE FACT
THAT MOST SENATORS CAN NAP
WITH HEIR EYES OPEN IT WOULD
BE CLEAR THE WHOLE CHAMBER
HAS BEEN UNCONSCIOUS SINCE
MONDAY.
CABLE NEWS, IT'S LIKE
CHRISTMAS.
"AMERICA'S NEWSROOMS" MAY BE
THE LAST PLACE IN THE
ENGLISH SPEAKING WORLD WHERE
ADAM SCHIFF IS STILL
CONSIDERED IMPRESSIVE.
TO THE AVERAGE NEWS ANCHOR
HE IS NOT A BUGGED EYE
HYSTERICAL HE A STATESMAN.
ALEXANDER HAMILTON REBORN.
GET THAT MAN A MUSICAL.
>> A VERY, VERY POWERFUL
AND FORCEFUL SPEECH ALMOST
TWO AND A HALF HOURS BY ADAM
SCHIFF.
VERY, VERY STRONG CASE.
>> I THOUGHT SCHIFF'S
PERFORMANCE WAS A VIRTUOSO
PERFORMANCE YESTERDAY.
>> ADAM SCHIFF DID
MASTERFULLY WHAT ALL
PROSECUTORS TRAINED TO DO HE
IS A REALLY GOOD LAWYER,
PERIOD, END OF DISCUSSION.
>> ALSO, I THOUGHT SCHIFF
DID EXCEPTIONALLY GOOD JOB
CONNECTING HIS CASE TO THE
FOUNDING FATHERS.
>> I HAVE TO SAY WATCHING
THAT I THOUGHT ADAM SCHIFF'S
OPENING WAS BRILLIANT.
>> THIS WAS A SPEECH REALLY
AIMED AT THE BETTER ANGELS.
>> BY MOST ACCOUNTS IT WAS A
VIRTUOSO PERFORMANCE THAT
DREW PRAISE FROM ALL SIDES
YESTERDAY.
A STUNNING RECITATION OF THE
FACTS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
PRESENTATION BY THE LEAD
HOUSE MANAGER ADAM SCHIFF?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS
DAZZLING.
>> Tucker: DAZZLING,
STUNNING, BRILLIANT,
POWERFUL, FORCEFUL,
MASTERFUL, VIRTUOSO,
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
THOSE ARE THE WORDS THE
PRESS USES TO DESCRIBE A MAN
WHO HAS JUST CALLED FOR A
HOT WAR AGAINST A NUCLEAR
ARMED NATION.
DO THE TALKING HEADS ON CNN
BELIEVE WHAT SCHIFF IS
SAYING?
DO THEY ACTUALLY THINK
RUSSIA IS ON THE CUSP OF
INVADING THE UNITED STATES?
MAYBE THEY DO.
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE NOT
REALLY LISTENING TO HIM.
IF THE INTERNAL THOUGHTS OF
YOUR AVERAGE NEWS ANCHOR
WERE BROADCAST ON THE
SCREEN, AND THEY SHOULD BE,
YOU WOULD SEE THEY REVOLVE
MOSTLY AROUND HAIR AND
MAKEUP DO.
MY EARS LOOK BIG?
THESE ARE NOT POLICY PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
DETAILS.
THEY JUST KNOW FOR CERTAIN
THAT SCHIFF IS ON THEIR
TEAM.
THAT'S ENOUGH FOR THEM.
THAT'S HOW THEY CAN SPEND
THE LAST THREE YEARS STUDY
DUSTILY PRETENDING THAT ADAM
SCHIFF IS A SERIOUS PERSON
AND NOT A WIDE EYED
CONSPIRACY NUT.
TO KEEP PRETENDING THAT THEY
NEED TO IGNORE A LOT OF HIS
ACTUAL CLAIMS THE THINGS HE
FAMED.
VERY MUCH INCLUDING THESE
THINGS:
>> YOU CAN SEE EVIDENCE IN
PLAIN SIGHT ON THE ISSUE OF
COLLUSION.
PRETTY COMPELLING EVIDENCE.
>> AND THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE AND
INDEED THERE IS OF COLLUSION
OF PEOPLE IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> I THINK THERE IS PLENTY
OF EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION OR
CONSPIRACY.
>> ALL OF THIS IS EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
>> Tucker: TO SCHIFF,
COLLUSION WAS EVERYWHERE, ON
FACEBOOK, ON TELEVISION,
INSIDE THE BOX OF HONEY
BUNCHES OF OATS SITTING IN
BREAKFAST NOOK OF HIS
APARTMENT.
AT ONE POINT HE SUSPECTED
HIS CAT, MANY CATS.
SCHIFF SPENT THE ENTIRETY OF
2017 AND 2018 TALKING JUST
LIKE THAT.
BY THE END HE WOULD ACCUSE
60 MILLION AMERICANS OF
COLLUDING WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN SIMPLY BY THE ACT OF
VOTING FOR DONALD TRUMP 2
WAS A CONSPIRACY THAT
PROFOUND.
EXCEPT IT WASN'T AND THAT'S
THE REMARKABLE PART.
SCHIFF WAS WRONG.
NONE OF THIS EVER HAPPENED.
AND WE NOW KNOW THAT
CONCLUSIVELY.
SO IS SCHIFF PUNISHED FOR
THIS?
DRIVEN FROM POLITE SOCIETY
FOR FALSELY IMPUGNING THE
INTEGRITY OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WITH LIES.
NO HE WASN'T.
HE GOT MORE FAMOUSED AND
MORE REVERED ON MSNBC.
YOU CAN FIND HIM MOST
WEEKDAYS NOW HAVING LUNCH IN
THE BEST RESTAURANTS IN THE
CITY RIGHT ACROSS FROM THE
GUYS WHO PLANNED THE IRAQ
WAR AND GOT RICH FROM
SUBSECURE PRIME TIME
MORTGAGES.
HE SEEMS HAPPY.
WHY WOULDN'T HE BE?
HE GOT IT ALL COMPLETELY
WRONG.
HE WASN'T PUNISHED.
HE WAS REWARDED.
THAT'S HOW WASHINGTON REALLY
WORKS.
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS YOU
WATCH ADAM SCHIFF STRUT